Octopus populations have been booming in the
last 60 years to the point where some marine
biologists even call them “the weeds of
the sea”.
Their main purpose in life is to breed and
make babies, but the way they do that is real
weird.
Check out this Facebook video we made to
see how... octopuses? Do the dirty.
Pretty crazy right? Those poor little guys. If you
wanna know more about how animals get it on,
check out our series “Wild Sex” on Seeker’s
Facebook page, Seeker Media.
In the meantime, if you’re curious what
happened after ancient humans and neanderthals
had sex, watch this video here.
Are there any other weird animals you want
to know more about?
Let us know down in the comments, be sure
to subscribe if you haven’t already and
thanks for watching Seeker!